hello and welcome to this talk about the
standardization of flow cytometry used
for evaluation of cellular immunotherapy
and solid organ transplantation
my name is matthias schweitz i am
administrator of the field cytometry
facility
in the institute of medical technology
at the charity university hospital in
berlin germany
and i'm also administrating the
humanitarian wireflow cytometry in
international clinical trials
but let's come to the topic
standardization of diagnostic tests and
procedures within
diagnostic laboratories
is the basic principle for the guarantee
of highly proved measurements
of diagnostic relevant values
that is true for simple staining
procedures and also for highly complex
analytical processes
but not only in the clinical diagnostics
also in the immune monitoring for
studying the effects of therapeutics has
become the standardization of analytical
methods of high importance
one of our most powerful tools for the
immune monitoring has become the flow
cytometry
because it's also one of the most
complex methods standartization is also
a challenge
i will show here the standardization of
the immune monitoring wireflow cytometry
for an international multi-center study
as an example for the necessary
procedures
the one study is a unified approach to
evaluating cellular immune therapy and
solid organ transplantation
and cell therapy is a novel concept for
immunoregulation
in this study aimed at
reducing transplant rejection after
kidney transplantation
and within the one study it is planned
to use different cell types with
immunosuppressive characteristics
to promote um protogenic responses to
inner aircraft
and assess the biological effect of
these regulatory immune cells in
comparison to an
independent clinical reference protein
in that trial it will be used standard
medication
the study is performed that trans
is performed at transplant centers
across europe and the use
within the one study trial it is planned
to test naturally occurring regulatory
cells so called antirex
the type one regulatory cells are called
ti-1 cells
the thyrogenic macrophages so-called
amorex
and
and also tolerogenic dendritic cells
predominantly
premium dominantly for their safety
so the second slide here
shows um the study design all trials
have a run time of 15 months whereas a
graph rejection is a primary endpoint
each center is performing the same
reference study using a standard
medication including an anti-25 antibody
straight after transplantation and
medication with steroids
mycophenolate morphetial and tachrolimus
at least the complete reference group
includes 60
patients monitored over the 50 months
after renal transplantation
the cell therapy study is a series of
independent trials
each center is using its own cell
product but the medication protocols are
similar
an anti-25 antibody will not be used and
in addition to a reduction of the
steroids it is also planned to reduce
the treatment with an
mmf
following experimental results for a
treatment with
immunoregulatory cells can be expected
various effects on the composition and
function of the recipient's immune
system population
a treatment could result in an increase
of
recipient regulatory subpopulations
may be also in an increase of dendritic
cell subsets or in reduction
of pathogenic memory tnb cells
it could be also increasing signs of
operational tolerance or in the worst
case scenario also an increase on
infectious complications
to be able to compare the effectiveness
of this alternative cellular
therapeutics the one study consultant
developed a robust immune monitoring
procedure
so we combined different analytical
tests
and we performing this test at different
time points
early we at least we have in combined
visit um career transplantation and nine
following
up visits after the transplantation
and where we performing the glycoside
profiling
via flow cytometry
retransplantation it and at eight
following time forms
we have also defined three additional
wizards
um
around the time point of the cell fusion
and these visits include also three
different analytical tests as well as
the glycoside profiling layer for
cytometry
within the immune monitoring we testing
the safety therefore we determine the
viral load especially for cmv evpn ebv
and also the level of hl adr on
monocytes as a sign of people depression
for paralysis
and we're performing immune monitoring
to test the efficacy of the cell
products so we combine gene expression
and determination the lymphocyte
profiling via flow cytometry we
determine the occurrence of anti-donor
hla antibodies or we look at the
stability of t-rex via the tstrd
methylation
within all these tests flow cytometry
together with different
pre-analytical factors
has the highest variability
therefore it is crucial to standardize
to standardize this method
in a paper by holden maker
it's named the model for harmonizing
flow cytometry in clinical trials
it is they are described
the main issues for a standardization
procedure
then flow cytometry
the three main complexes are the issues
of site of instrument setup the issues
of sample handling and the issues of
data analysis
these three complexes bearing a lot of
variables that need to be controlled to
measure at least accurate and precise
data with the least variation among
different sites
but we have to keep in mind that the
reduction of variability
also could lead to an increase of the
workflow and we have to find the balance
between that both spots
in last autumn they came up a really
interesting guide for validation of
cell-based fluorescence essays published
in cytometry rb
and in
this paper
is pointed out that there's a problem to
determine the accuracy
of the flow cytometry test because
according to the iso definition
accuracy is the closeness of agreement
between the average value obtained from
a large series of test results and an
acceptable reference value but the
problem is that we have a lack of fully
characterized reference material
and at least there is also problem to
find material with variations of target
molecule molecule levels and because
flow cytometry is so complex
it is also
not sufficient to compare other
analytical muscles methods with flow
cytometry
at least we can only estimate the
accuracy of this test
within our study we use the so-called
mix model for the validation and the
standardization it is also described in
the paper holden maker
we defined a central monitoring map that
is our lab here in vernon
and we developed consensual together
with the
essay performing laboratories and also
with our industrial partner vacuum coder
the
panels and we developed also the saps
we did together with vacuum culture also
the panel validation and we defined the
reference standards
in the second step in the
standardization we transferred the
panels and the sops and additional
informations about the reference
standards to the essay performing
laboratories
at this
laboratories we did a cytometer set up
there is now doing the sample processing
according to the sop and the data
acquisition
after data acquisition all the data
are
transferred to the central moon
monitoring net and we doing here
centralized the data analysis at least
only by one analyst to have a reduced
bias
wire analysis
there's a basic principle for
standardization the basic principle is
keep it as simple as possible
and you have to keep it in mind if you
answer at the different question that
has to be answered so there are
pre-analytical questions the first
question is which matrices
we
should
use
at least we decided to doing whole blood
surface staining because we are not only
interested in the relative values of the
different glycoside populations we are
also interested in the absolute
concentration of these cell populations
and we decided to use as an
anticoagulant and the coefficients
edta because we are
doing a surface stain
at least we are using one single sop
within um
the staining of all panel
it is a simple sop
only surface staining combined with the
local sidewises and fixation
and combined with the washing steps to
reduce the background
and we
had to perform a second sop
because for the diesel identification of
the visa population it is necessary to
reduce the serum concentration of the
igm and we are also interested because
because they are in they are some rare
population to concentrate the b cells
within results within the sample
therefore we added a
additional washing step for your surface
staining but then we followed the same
slp
that enables to use one unique
cytometer setting for all the design
patterns
so
now let's have a look on the antibody
pattern the first antibody panel allows
the enumeration of all major lycosite
subsets such as granulocytes monocytes
lymphocytes
and as well um
in cases
with the other five panels more detailed
analyzers can be studied on t-cell
activation
t-effector cell differentiation
regulatory
b cell differentiation
and dendritic cell subsets
in all panels we use the uni we are
using a unique backbone a cd45
background bone we need this backbone
for the calculation of absolute values
and we are using the white blood cell
count and of the hematology department
as a reference for calculating this
values
and in all t solar panels we have also
unique backbone
um by the marcus cd34
ncaa
at least we are using within all the
panels
and for identical markers into the same
clothes
after
fixing the formulation of this panel the
panels never changed
and additional panels will be designed
with respect to the backbone and with
respect to the used antibody clouds
all these panels in bee study are
briefly configure are previous as
pre-configured electric mixes and
immonotag beckman culture and then
shipped to the different centers that
enables a high quality
for all
used antibody panels
because it is not
possible to determine the accuracy it is
necessary to test the imprecision
of um
of the panels and the stability
imprecision tests are the intra essay
test to estimate a tube to tube
consistency
they have the inter operator test to
estimate the variance by operator
and there is a inter essay test to
estimate the day-to-day variance
the problem if you are dealing with a
whole blood essay
like in this study
is that you cannot use stabilized whole
blood for the estimation of the
day-to-day variant because if you're
interested in markers like c07 it is
impossible to stain such stabilized
blood therefore you have to draw blood
each day and that gives an additional
biological variance in this test
this biological additional vital
variance increases the
cvs for this test
the stability is tested for the matrix
so you are looking at the aging of your
whole blood
and you are interested in the aging of
your stained samples
this is a short overview for
one of the panels for the interoperator
test and the intra essay test
at least we had really nice
low cvs for the interactive test
for the
most
population less than 10 percent
and for some populations
less than 20 percent
also the inter-operator tests
is comparable to this intra as a test
but what does it mean to have a cv up to
10 or 20 or 30 percent is it really good
that we have in cv less than 20 for
population with variance
but diagnostic procedures
you're dealing with a cut-off value for
a diagnostic
purpose
and for such tests you have to define
the acceptable variance before you're
starting validation procedure but in the
immune monitoring you do not have such
kind of
cutoff value
therefore you have to record the
variability of your panels
so therefore we define such precision
profiles
at least we plotted the
observed cvs
for
um each population in the intra essay
test
in the
in the right
column here
um where those the
size relative size of the population
in the left column here
where this the
absolute counted events for each
population and the middle column
to be
abs calculated absolute value
then
we did in best fit
where we looked at the best fit call
and um calculated the 95 percent here
to find an upper limit for
um
the quantitation
that means
for our test
we are finding um
cv up to 20 percent here we have a
population size about 0.18
even
decreasing variability up to 5
if we have populations greater than
15.61
the same is true if you look on the
counted event
and that is not necessarily compared to
the relative size of an subpopulation
if you are counting
45 events
you will have an either csv about 20
and you have to count more than
1570 events
to
get in cv less than 5
the upper limit shows you that in the
worst case scenario you have to count
more than 2000 events to get a cv less
than five percent
this procession profile
gives you at least an overview
about the imprecision of your test
this graph shows you
that
beside the interoperator test and intra
as it has you have an increasing
variability for the stability
and the first row in blue you see the
intra essay test
but in the
with the other colors in dark red you
see the age of blood 24 hours
contain here
the age of blood four hours in dark
orange
age of staying 24 hours
under the light orange here age of stain
four hours
let's have a look at a population that
is
not so
great not so big population so let's
have a look at this
cd28
negative cd4 positive effector cell
population given
slightly increased cv
also for the intro essay test here
but then you see
also an increase for the age of stain
after flowers
but a high increase here after 24 hours
after the sustaining procedure
the same is true also for the age of
blood
so you have
year small increase of the cv within
four hours
um of
after proper
of the preparation after donation of the
blood but a
really high increase of cv after 24
hours
at least we decided then
that we have to sustain the material
four hours or within four hours after
the donation of the budget and we have
to measure all the samples also within 4
hours after the preparation of the
sample
after we finishing the
validation procedure we started the
standardization and therefore we had
chosen a calibrator in our study we are
using closer beads synthetic bead
particle with a defined mfe value for
each channel but you can use also other
synthetical beads like the rainbow beads
if you also define mfe values for
android all of the pro sensor channels
but we are using this calibrator not
only to do a pnt setup we are using it
also for quality control
so we are measuring the flow cell beads
each day before the measurement of the
samples with the same settings but
without the compensation and we are
tracking the results for each channel
over the time
if we see it then
the variance of this mfe value for a
channel
more than five percent we are starting
again the setup procedure to set up the
machine to the target value
after defining the target
values
we
provided all this information together
with the information about the b plot to
the asset performing laboratories
then we performed the cytometer setup
via auto setup procedure at the sa
performing laboratories
and then we did an interlaboratory
comparison
the results of this comparison are shown
here
therefore we shipped whole blood samples
from the central moon monitoring lab to
all of the um assay performing
laboratories
and then we performed the
stainings to the same point at all these
centers
because we have this large distance
between berlin and san francisco and we
had to deal with 30 age and 30 hours
aged whole blood
but with this information in mind it is
really nice to see that we have
only a slow increase of cvs for
population for the population with more
rare events
so the effector subpopulation city for
effect or subpopulation
but for
population
they are
bigger
like these here we have really small cvs
also within the interlaboratory test
all these results all this procedure is
published in this paper and
is also nice nicely to find at this open
source platform transplantation research
but after finishing standardization
validation we are also interested in a
terminal improvement then we are
interested to harmonize other studies
with
our one study
so there's in
second transparent huge transplantation
trials of biodrum and for that trial we
designed um
also the panels using the one study
panels as the
basic
and
improvement
as one example we used the
panel for the t cell subsets
and combine two additional markers
because in recent
in recent publications
it could be shown that a ratio of the v
delta 1 and v delta 2 cells
give us information about an upcoming
operational tolerance therefore we added
these markers to the run study panel
then we designed a additional
intracellular staining panel because in
the one study we had we had not a
mandatory intracellular panel we tested
once
that we improved by additional markers
because because we are interested here
also in the direct subpopulations
therefore we have now in this panel not
only a fox p3 staining and a 25 staining
together the city for cd3 and 45
we are also sustaining helios grand zone
b and 45 r8
all these panels now
formulated as multi-colored multicolored
cocktail and panels in single tube
format with a new dried reagent
technology so called duracloth
that enables us
first of all to reduce the preparation
steps because it's not necessary to pipe
up an antibody anymore
and we have a
higher stability of the samples because
they're dried and workflows are more
stable than the pre-mixed liquid colors
and it is now much easier to ship these
panels
to other laboratories
the one study panels and the biogram
panels we are now using harmonized in
different trials
in the reference study of the blind
study we now enrolled
almost all patients so we have now
involved 60 patients in that study
then we started now with the therapy
study at two centers
and we performed a healthy control group
now apply
also other international centers to the
one study panels so that we think that
we will have an increasing data pool
in the biodrum panel we plan to enroll
more than 350 patients
and we are using similar at the same
panels than the one study and some of
the improved patterns
and we harmonized also our immune
monitoring in smaller trials and smaller
studies in our um in our own laboratory
here
so
we get
at least results from liver
transplantation studies from cardiology
studies or from studies about diabetes
and high phosphates
but
we are also interested
in the optimization
of the intel platform optimization of
the inter platform standard development
because we are using a
bright mfe target
we will have we will have after the
standardization procedure at each
cytometer the same mfe target for the
positive value
the problem is if you have different
filter setups or different laser power
in the system so different laser for
the excitation of the plural chromes you
will see a shifting of the negative
population so that's the discrimination
of
two population can be
can become complicated
therefore we are
really pleased that we have an highly
discriminating
um
population so america for almost the
most populations here shown for the c
19 positive v cells and here for the
pdcs
crucial visit at least for that
population this modulated marker
especially if there is um
there are rare populations
like the cd 56 high
in k cells or the transitional b sites
we did these inter-platform
standardization our own laboratory using
liquid antibody mixers and the duraclone
antibody mixes of the same panels
and then we measured the samples on
the reference machine for the one study
trial
and also at a second platform
on the left column to see the results
for
the b cell population and the t cell
population the t cell subpopulations for
the liquid antibody mix at our reference
machine in the middle column for the
dura clone mixes of the same sample same
for the same material
and in the right column
you see the results measured on a
different platform with similar settings
the results are highly comparable
to proof our test we analyzed um
healthy cohort in that cohort this time
we included 50 tn2 patients
and
these 50 or 52 healthy control
individuals
and
that covers 26 males 26 females and we
can split up this in five different age
groups
so we have an
well
gender and
age mesh match group
now we did in one way anova to identify
the 10
populations with the highest
discrimination discriminating capacity
um between different groups
and you see here
the five different age groups so in
white the group from 20 to 30 years
and in like the group from 60 to 75
years
and if you
look on the
left side
the heat map here
we are starting on the right side with
the younger symbols and have on the left
side
the samples
of the
older
population
and for
eight markers here
we see an
increase because it turns to blue of
that subpopulations within
a decrease of this population we've seen
an increase of the age only for two of
its populations
here is shown that this population
increasing
with h
the final result fits very well with the
published results in the recent
literature
because it is not surprising that naive
t-rex
decreased with age
whereas the memory compartment of the
t-rex
is increasing with age
we did the olson anova one-way anova
within
age-corrected um
samples or with the h corrected values
and therefore
therefore we found also
interesting
discriminations between the female
and the male groups
at least
in that sample is shown
that
in
more in the male group you will find
more effective cells where the
population with the factor cells
are decreased more in the female
fingertip
not only to prove our tests it is
necessary to use this that healthy
control group it is also necessary to
further compare our patient cohort with
that age and gender match controls
because you see the differences in
certain populations
by aging
as a second test we use the results
of the
pre-transplantation time point
look at the
um
sub-populations also with the highest
discriminated
capacity
so here
on pink you have the healthy group and
you have the
kidney transplantation group in blue
and the patient with a non-confirmed
rejection in yellow
in that patient
with
a time point prior transplantation
you find a decrease of almost seven
main population including also the pdcs
and you found an increase for two of
this population here
comparing the results with the healthy
control you can clearly see for the pdcs
that you have an increasing of the pdc's
while aging for the healthy controls in
black
and you have a much more decreased level
of pdcs
for the patients
before transplantation
using this that seven subcells
we performed in principle component
analysis to identify a phenotype for
these different groups
surprisingly we found
that the healthy phenotype
is more comparable to the yellow
phenotype here
of the kidney transplantation
group with a non-confirmed rejection
whereas the phenotype of the
patients they didn't got in rejection
clear transplantation is much more
different from the healthy control and
from the
patients their guardian rejection
but these are only the first results of
the study more to prove our immune
monitoring
because most of these
results are published and we can compare
it
so we are not now highly interested in
the combination
more to combine data the data analysis
using the data of all analytical tests
for instance the tsvr demutilation or
anti-donor antibodies
or the other analytical tests and we are
also working in
the further optimization of the test
because we are highly interested in
reducing the variability
and improves the standardization
procedure and also improving the
analytical depth of the data analysis
we are interested in a further
development of other panel using the one
backbone and also in the optimization of
the standardization
maybe via other reagent platforms
we also hope that we can help to develop
a fast and
reproducible whole blood functional
assay test in pre-coated dry down tubes
incorporating stimulus
and we will go further
or remove
from the peripheral blood test
also to graph a graph and biopsy
staining with our panels
and as a really big
complex of interest
we also look at the past analytical
issues because we are highly interested
in reducing the buyers by data analysis
and we hope
that there is a development of
bioinformatic tools for data
interpretation
there are four main complexes
the main complex for reducing bias while
data analysis is automatic flow gating
so there are two possibilities
supervised and answers supervised
automatic flow data
but it is also necessary to develop
other statistical tools and
classification algorithm
and improve the data visualization
at the end we hope that especially with
the harmonization within other studies
he can doing a data sharing of this
increasing data pools using the bug
panels
at least
i shouldn't forget
to um
point out the most
important factor for the variability
from the test
this is
the communication and the training
and i'm really happy that in our
consortium in the one study we are
highly we have a really good
communication between all partners we
have a really ongoing project
and we have a really great cooperation
uh collaboration
between the asset performing
laboratories
our industrial partner and the central
human monitoring
so i'd like to say thank you for your
attention
and i would move forward to
upcoming questions
so the first question by james is here
where were samples collected did you
control for logistical variations
yes in the centers we are doing we
because we are doing an on-site staining
of the samples we have really short ways
from the
place where the sample
for the where the blood is drawing to
the
staining place
and for the inter laboratory test we
controlled also the logistical variables
if possible
so we reported the change of temperature
within all these
transport procedures
so
if there are
no additional questions to this talk
i would say thank you again
yeah and i wish you a good day
you